[Musique]
donc la voilà donc là dans le noyau dur
des arbitres à a- à mayol 1
[Musique]
merci avec vous
à cette 53e soirée du piano-bar
pierre-marie jazz dans un instant
matthieu delormeau
berhanu chanter une des chansons qui lui
est cher pour un flirt avec toi
[Musique]
merci battue
pourquoi ce soir c'est que je fais tout
ce je vais tous vous présenter avec une
chanson d'accord aux quilles avec nous
ce soir benjamin castaldi
allez-y benjamin castaldi et donnez moi
la chanson que vous voulez vous allez
voir je connais toutes les paroles aller
seul envie non comme dans l'obscurité
puis la lumière qu'on me donne alors oui
la fin puis ça fait stars comme l'un de
ceux qui est vain et secondaires pour
que je retrouve l'esprit de la vie enfin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'on vous donne la reprise
alors il s'agira d'une manière à les
[Applaudissements]
peines ont été de lucio battisti peine
qui va mal c'est tout c'est bon
masqué le bal masqué
[Applaudissements]
tél
mathé
amassés
non
alors qu'elle allait aux dépens les
costumes la pole et c'est un vrai
plaisir de respecter les coutumes joseph
est tolérée merci
bonsoir hébreu banc des blues brothers
en le regardant je déteste les rats ont
fait à bas alors un emile et images les
démons de minuit tatatata 14 dernière
cigarette
bouh justin
[Applaudissements]
ses talons aiguilles et ceux des hommes
ça met un peu de chaleur où ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
alors dans le mois d'août avec mother
luc merci
bonne chance au château louis crazy frog
bada parties doivent peut vous faire
plus simple en sixième mercredi fraude
c'est là qu'elle sait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qu'on attend bitat pourquoi pas
le lieu qu'elle a fait avec maître
ginter game over vita et maître gims
habitat
[Musique]
devait sauver j'ai envie de manger et
manger manger j'ai encore merci les gars
comme moi comme moi c'est comme les
masses comme toi si tu habites à bessat
voilà merci j'ai gardé
[Applaudissements]
angie andalouse à un gars n'ont bien sûr
cartonne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok je te vois dans ces communes
j'avais dépensé dans les cieux
je
aïe aïe
toi toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais
m salah
bon allez pour à terme du tour
maintenant du côté des années 1880 un
jeune chanteur émergent très vite c'est
bobby boby lapointe
elle me marcel amont le bleu ciel de
provence son nom alors c'est elle qui
choisit non au choix vas-y francky c'est
bon ou le france de sardou quand je
pense à la vieille anglaise qu'on
pouvait pas fermez vos gueules
alors oui la plus belle chanson oh oui
ça parle et ça va mais là derrière
matthieu delormeau
c'est quand même quelqu'un il a fédéré
il a fait les beaux jours des marges est
douce et hervé
allez vous connaissez le chanteur qui
prennent le micro comme ça ex prennent
pour des grands beaux gosses du chrono
allez-y s'il vous plaît je t'aime lara
fabian
tony parker
munich
[Musique]
c'est un tout
d'accord il existait vraiment tout face
ou de ceux qui tueraient quelques éclats
de verre aurait peut-être nous c'est non
peu farouche mais les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons qu'on n'aurait pas
g
[Musique]
coût de l'oseraie jeu
super
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
[Musique]
mais
tu as tort
[Applaudissements]
alors alors tu peux chanter ouais alors
on y comptait bien et le mal je reprends
ton micro tu reprends tes cliqueter
claqué technique la map le mois ville
inquiète avec nos nerfs solides nos
frères ayew on vivre ça en tandem
we love you
[Applaudissements]